will we ever see Donald Trump's tax
returns we've had a poll at david
pakman.com for a couple of weeks this is
not a scientific poll this is merely a
reflection of the opinions of those in
our audience who chose to participate in
the poll and the audience feels about
that question as follows will we ever
see full and complete tax returns from
Donald Trump 31% of our audience
believes that we definitely won't and
47% of our audience believes that we
probably won't ever see Donald Trump's
tax return that means that 78% of our
audience believes that it is not likely
we will see Trump's tax returns 9%
believe we will probably see Donald
Trump's tax returns at some point six
percent believe we will definitely see
Donald Trump's tax returns and 7 percent
have absolutely no idea I come down on
the side of probably won't I still am
sort of holding out hope that somehow
there will be a mechanism that makes
public Donald Trump tax returns but I
believe that we probably will not what
do you mean we saw the first two pages
from his 2005 1040 form so isn't that
good enough yeah that really told us a
lot right we did learn one thing from
that much-publicised Rachel Maddow a
bombshell so-called bombshell about
Trump's tax returns which is if he gets
rid of the alternative minimum tax which
his tax plan seeks to do he will pay way
less in taxes personally so there was
actually in the end something useful
about that I think there's two possible
ways that we could end up seeing Donald
Trump's tax returns one is that they get
hacked okay and that the other is that
the Democrats take back control of the
house in 2018 and because they'll be in
charge of the Ways and Means Committee
and the Judiciary Committee they might
be able to request his tax returns from
the Treasury Department though that's
what I see the only other number three I
would put is if something drastically
changes that we can't even imagine now
maybe it creates an incentive for Trump
to release them like right now releasing
them would be worse than the status quo
maybe something gets turned so
upside-down that Trump releases them in
order to prevent something from getting
even worse than we can imagine but I
have no idea what that would be it's
hard to imagine what that would be
especially because 74% of Americans want
to see Donald Trump's tax returns
something that we clamored him for
during the campaign and wanting to
see them and yet they refuse to do it
even now even what's the audit end I I
generally agree I doubt we're going to
see them new poll at david pakman.com
how will Donald Trump's accomplishments
in his second hundred days compared to
the first hundred days you can vote at
david pakman.com we will have poll
results on a future program